you know I've had the interesting the
interesting career of training for many
things and then having a career mostly
in things they never trained for after
graduate school I became a postdoc with
Stephen Hawking where we were working on
quantum theories of gravity basically
they were trying to understand the
fundamental structure of space and time
and where the universe came from I took
a leave of absence from that to work on
a software project supposed to be for
three months and it turned out to me for
the rest of my life after a couple
months working on the software project
we decided to start a company I became
the CEO of that company
we ran the company for two years then
Microsoft bought us and I became the
first chief technology officer at
Microsoft where I was for 14 years
worked directly for Bill Gates and was
able to participate in the PC revolution
it's a magic time because software
through personal computing empowered
literally billions of people to take
charge of the information in their lives
to be creative whether it was with a
word processor or a spreadsheet or an
art package leading up to the Internet
which is the ultimate information
distribution system for the planet now
along the way I've been interested in a
dozen other things I've always been
interested in science it's after
training in many fields of science I
didn't actually professionally pursue
them but I have been interested in
dinosaurs for example for the last 15
years I've done a lot of dinosaur
research published a number of papers on
dinosaurs and have been the main sponsor
and co-lead an expedition with Jack
Horner where we found more t-rex's than
anyone else in the world has ever found
t-rexes and lots of other dinosaurs
besides that when I retired from
Microsoft that was a difficult thing to
do because I was very successful at
Microsoft I was chief technology officer
of the company it was still an amazing
time for the company and for technology
now of course once I'd been at Microsoft
for awhile I had
the resources where I could start over
and it wasn't like I was afraid of
starving but it isn't always an issue
when you're good at something just say
do I keep getting better at that thing
or do I switch to something else for me
it's been pretty easy to switch to other
things because I get interested in them
and once I get interested in them
there's no turning back so it's always
difficult to leave something you know
for something you don't particularly if
you're good at it if you're not good at
it and you get fired or you screw up
it's easy to leave the world forces that
on you but if it's your decision it's
tough but it's also your life and if you
don't take charge of it no one will take
charge of it for you the only
institution in life where you get time
off for good behavior is prison you know
in most jobs or most careers the better
you are at it the more you're sucked
into it you get the big promotion you
get more responsibilities you get more
success and that could tends to narrow
your options not increase them but
what's the point of success if you don't
have your own options and you don't make
your own decision so for that reason I
decided I had to really make a decision
and ultimately I decided I would leave
Microsoft and as great as that
experience was for me at Microsoft I'm
thrilled that I left and I've made
something of a life for myself since
then